[Music]
hi everyone this is Miguel concepción
editor gamespot along with tech editor
Michael hi I'm here to check out this
new build of Gran Turismo sport we're
gonna start with the tutorial component
of the campaign but after that we'll
check out how to dress up a car in the
new livery editor and then flaunt our
ride in the escapes photo mode if you're
psyched about GT sport give us a like
and subscribe to our Channel and let us
know what feature of the game you're
most excited about while you're there
you can check out our recent coverage of
project cars - for more simulation
Racing goodness let's get to it so Mike
this is a the latest build we're
checking out a race in the tutorial to
campaign you have played grant who
support through the beta doing quite
well yeah you could say that you placed
what I think what our seventh place like
out of 12 people I think that fourth
place isn't too bad right so now we're
checking out the menus Gran Turismo has
been known and famous for their you eyes
sometimes you know they definitely have
this slick unique flavor to them even if
sometimes they may not be the easiest
menus to navigate through what do you
think of this one so far it reminds me
of the OG Gran Turismo like it has that
that style with the cursor and you know
you flip through all these different
options so it's it's nothing like
terribly new to Gran Turismo but it
certainly does look nice even though it
can be a little cluttered it's kind of
what you expect from Gran Turismo but
it's as like a like a clean aesthetic
and then so yeah we're checking out some
Amy Winehouse facts as well yeah it's
it's definitely has its own style I mean
I definitely haven't played other racing
games you can definitely see the
influence that Gran Turismo has made on
those games where yeah definitely
they've really all these British racing
developers that put a lot of effort into
their menus and whatnot but yeah these
interesting music and historical
factoids there's actually this I
remember seeing this one slide
recognizing Tim berners-lee's
contribution as the as the credited
inventor of the World Wide Web as it
relates to the world of simulation
racing some like that it says hey I see
it as the folks that pull it from the
digital seeing the evolution of cars or
something as significant as music
milestones and music or milestones in
computer technology
speaking of milestones we're looking at
the driving school here where we can
complete the many milestones and make
ourselves a better racer what can you
tell me about what you know well with
driving school well the great Gran
Turismo has a really rich history of
having these robust training modes
I mean it's is it's Demick --that it
takes a lot of effort to master
simulation game I mean after all if
you're gonna be good enough to actually
be good at a racing game what are you
doing playing a video game right you
should be out there competing sure we're
going along with driving school the game
puts you in a whole bunch of challenges
outside of actual online or Tournament
races you could literally spend you
could spend dozens of hours just on
these training modes before even
starting on the campaign just that's how
robust this section is so is this these
are one of the challenges we're looking
at right here correct you just have to
pass simply pass three cars which is
easier said than done
what we'll find out here is we ended up
placing third which is out of three
right or does four racers it's enough to
pass but I'm pretty sure that there are
rewards optional rewards for getting
yeah for getting first so so I mean it
looks like it's it's very similar to the
license tests in past Gran Turismo z--
where if you get a certain time or if
you get like a certain place within one
will sectional pieces of
whatever you're racing on you'll get
gold silver bronze and maybe maybe more
credits alright I suppose so that makes
sense so it's very familiar to the Gran
Turismo brand right getting getting at
least third well it will allow you to
access the later areas of the game but
it's you're not get snot gonna you're
not gonna be gate capped if you don't
get first okay yeah that makes sense
I mean yeah back and I think the
original Gran Turismo you uh you're kind
of capped by your ability to get through
those those driving tests and it was it
was kind of difficult for newcomers so
at least you know it's a little bit more
accessible in this regard if you're not
you know like you said Gate it off if
you don't finish those challenges this
other mode that we're checking out is a
called circuit experience which lets you
focus and train on specific sections of
the tracks available in the game some of
the tracks are exclusive to Gran Turismo
as some other famous tracks active
Nurburgring you've played that many
times in other racing games so yeah yeah
look this looks really helpful for
trying to learn a track because you know
you don't always want to do the entire
lap just to get to that one section that
you constantly want to write try out or
or like you would do sometimes just
reverse and then try it again so that
that looks like a neat feature for those
who are serious about you know nailing
down those those tight turns in specific
tracks without having to spend all that
time to get back into that section so
that's pretty cool and after all I mean
every professional racer knows those
nuances and curves of those tracks so
kind of makes you sore develop that put
you're on the road to developing that
sort of muscle memory yeah it's more
those tracks one of the things that the
menu also highlighted is this mode
called etiquette where it basically
encourages and trains you and rewards
you for being a courteous driver
oh yeah additive but not the type that
would just like keep bumping other cars
yeah that showed up in the beta as well
so I saw that and I kind of got an idea
of it was like now I'm not gonna
bump try and bump anyone off-track
otherwise we would get a slap on the
wrist and it's messed up anyway man I
think I want to try and not knock anyone
out of the track but uh yeah now we're
looking at the delivery yes delivery
editor there's one feature that we're
very very excited about partly because
we got GameSpot branding out of the box
you'll be able to play around with our
logo when you buy the game make it
bigger everyone guys see that
yeah I cremated a little too big so I'm
gonna scale it scale it back a bit any
of you Photoshop fans will recognized a
little bit of influence from the
Photoshop you I would they even use the
term layers yeah we've seen a lot of I
mean over the years as racing games have
evolved we've seen a lot of these decal
editors and you know things that we can
do to our own personal cars in the game
to make them look however we want so I
expect nothing less from Gran Turismo
and I'm excited to see that you know how
how deep can it go I know like Forza
Motorsport has had that for a while and
then in you know Need for Speed
Underground series is when I first kind
of started tinkering with the cars looks
so I want to like get you know see what
kind of paint jobs that we can get what
kind of decals we can do and how we can
layer all that because even like in old
order motorsports we've seen like some
pretty crazy designs create like your
very very creative stuff and segwaying
from delivery editor is escapes which is
where we get to flaunt and showcase our
imaginative car liveries yeah this this
runs the risk of a looking photoshopped
itself right yeah polyphony digital I
think has made a pretty good effort in
trying to adapt the lighting of these
photos to the cars and we were told that
out of the box there's gonna be over a
thousand backgrounds of real world
places you get to choose from I'll snap
so yeah we go we're here in Japan with
our was it Aston Martin looks like
or - whoa it says right there
mercedes-benz it's an AMG Wow and you
can tweak a whole bunch of photo
settings
that's that should not surprise anyone
who's played around with a lot of Sony
first party games like me think about
like horizon zero dawn the kinds of like
photo modes you can play and you know
it's not a hundred percent there yeah I
don't know if you could like fool a lot
of your friends to make you think that
your car that you managed to bring your
car to Japan but who knows way maybe
with all these settings you can find a
way to make that work
you know I've also you know I I first
started messing around with these types
of photo modes for racing games and I
remember doing this in Need for Speed
Underground - that was a real fun and
like you mentioned you know the extends
to other games like horizon zero dawn
where you can like kind of just you know
make your own photos and look and look
make them look real photo realistic and
yeah and having it's real fun it's a
nice touch these extreme blur effects so
that's it for now and we hope you
enjoyed this brief showcase into the
latest build of Gran Turismo sport for
more gameplay previews and be sure to
check us out on GameSpot calm and on
YouTube Mike thanks a lot for your time
thank you